غزة ستستمر في
التدمير والطمس والسحق على ما
أعتقد على
المستوى السياسي العسكري وليس لدي أي
خبرة خاصة في المسائل العسكرية على الإطلاق.
لا أحد قال إنني أود أن أقول إن هناك
العوامل التالية التي يجب أخذها في الاعتبار
العامل الأول هو ما إذا كان حزب الله
سيفتح ثانيًا
أعتقد أن بقاء البشرية سيكون
في خطر،
ولن أشك في أن إسرائيل ستستخدم أنواعًا من
الأسلحة ليس فقط ضد حزب الله، بل
ضد
إيران، مما سيعرض بقاء
البشرية للخطر، ولن أنصحهم إذا
سألوا عما لن يفعلوه.  "لا
أطلب منهم
الامتناع، لن أطلب منهم المضي قدمًا، وفي
كلتا الحالتين تلوح كارثة في الأفق رقم اثنين، هناك
مسألة ما إذا كانت إسرائيل ستشن غزوًا
بريًا، وهو سؤال كبير
إذا حدث ذلك، فما مدى أهمية
مقاومة حماس إذا"
المقاومة كبيرة إذن نتنياهو ستضطر
إسرائيل إلى
الانسحاب أو حفظ ماء الوجه. قد تفعل إسرائيل
شيئا جنونيا تماما لأنهم
لا يمكن أن يتعرضوا لكارثة ثانية بعد
7 أكتوبر تماما مثل
الكارثة إذا تدخل حزب الله
أو إذا لم يتدخل حزب الله.  وفي كلتا
الحالتين إنها
كارثة